you turned down James Bond not really
yes no no no no I got it no I got a call
from my agent saying they're interested
in you for Bond and they want to know if
it's something you're interested in
right
and I took that as uh they're gonna ask
it's a bit like the Secret Service
they're not they don't want to offer it
to you and you say no right so no one
probably rejected there were canvassing
six or seven people and at the time I
at the time I was like well I've got
I've got X-Men and I know I'm going to
an X-Men 2 right I actually rang Russell
and got advice for him about I said man
what do you think I should do
and he said to me he goes you make sure
you know the direction it's going in man
because you're going to be if you say
yes to that and it works you've got
X-Men Bond X-Men Bond X-Men Bond so you
want to make sure you're doing something
that you really love and and I remember
him going back and saying I I said okay
before I say yes or no like who's
directing it and where we add and I
thought it kind of needed a bit of a
change yeah and and they said oh no no
you just sign on I was like ah you know
it's not for me and in my head I
remember saying to my age and I said I
think it should I feel it's got to go
back to being a little more Sean Connery
there's a little tougher and maybe you
know anyway so I go to see Casino Royale
I was like oops
is that the worst feeling at this point
you don't give a [__] I mean because no
that was fine the worst feeling was
Chicago watching Chicago because I I'd
weirdly come I I never thought I would
do musicals that was a huge shock to me
that I got into musicals right yeah so I
I but now I've got offers in movies and
I can do musicals and I'm thinking well
hopefully I'll get to do a movie Musical
and that one came to me the and uh I
thought I was way too young well I was
too young I was 30 planed apart and he's
got a line uh the character he goes I've
seen it all kid yeah to Renee zellweg
and I was like I'm the same age as well
I'm a 30 year old I said I don't think I
can pull that off right and when I went
to watch the movie my Palms were
sweating because the moment it opened up
I I was going uh I really should have
just said let's put some makeup on let's
go old oh by the way Richie gave us uh
so perfect for it I actually kind of a
bit disappointed myself I tell you that
story but I've told it before about
otherwise as a winner because I always
think it's a little
you know Richard Gere said I'm going
really dude like you're telling the
world like I you know you were offered a
first like thanks pal but I think that
there's such a passage of time in the
guy was so successful with it yeah
you're not I don't think you're hurting
him by saying I don't think and I think
Daniel Craig doesn't give a [__] either
you know what I mean no he doesn't we're
good mates and and by the way he would
have got the same call I got I have
since heard a bunch of people uh got
that call
yeah
foreign